I believe that stylish speech whatever  makes you feel comfortable and feeling  comfortable I believe it's great for  your success when I wake up in the  morning if I have a game I will put on  my white pants I grab my helmet on my  back mallet go to the barn and get ready  for for the game my favorite thing to  wear is my portable these boots were  made to measure in Argentina by a guy  called Logano they have my initials feel  and s for nacho fajita in polo when  you're playing tournaments or games you  are required to wear white pants mine  are just Whitey's regular white jeans  the shirt is the Serta my team which put  the black boot spoiler team it's also a  brand inside of us Lauren it has the  number in the bag which is the number of  the position that you play  I feel most comfortable when I'm on the  Bulacan so my whole outfit is what I  like the most  I'm a classy guy